your belief is that putin is
sick and may not have long to live
clearly he is seriously ill i mean how
terminal or incurable it is is not clear
blood cancer
parkinson's
paranoia
as the war in ukraine grinds on
speculation is mounting about vladimir
putin's physical and mental health
you can see him aging you can see him
being bloated you can see him not being
quite as active as he had been before
are these rumors wishful thinking
propaganda
or based in fact
and what might this speculation mean for
putin's grip on power
[Music]
so the rumors are that putin has cancer
that he has blood cancer
there are rumors also that he has
parkinson uh the rumors that uh he's
hurt his back uh very badly years ago
when he has fallen off the horse there
are rumors that he is not making a
rational decisions so there are two ways
of explaining why there are so many
rumors circulating around putin's health
one of course is political if you like
that there are so many people
around putin now who realize that he has
made this extraordinary blunder that
he's driven uh russia into this
catastrophic war there are a lot of
people who see uh and wish for the best
way out of it which is putin dying
in office and that's why i think there
is um there is a sort of wishful
thinking thinking okay he might go then
we'll be out of uh out of this complete
mess
so that's one reason uh
this this room is circulating the other
of course is the possibility that he is
very very seriously ill
we don't have we can't verify this
uh the rumors about putin's health
started circulating you know have been
circulating for for a long time and
intensified after the beginning of the
war when krista grossif uh of ballencat
the open source investigative
outlet put out a story
their investigation that that
putin is surrounded by
by doctors that he had
something like 35 visits from cancer
specialists um
and then there were you know these were
reinforced by um
some russian oligarchs in exile
presumably somebody close to putin
talking to the media saying yes he has
cancer he has a blood cancer
you can see him aging you can see him
being bloated you can see him
not being uh
quite as active as he had been before if
you look at way putin walked uh from
red square
to the term of the unknown soldier
in
around the kremlin during the 9th of may
parade you can see he is walking
somewhat was difficult you can see he's
sort of dragging his
left
leg and
he has limited control over
his arm whether that's parkinson or
whether that's something else we
obviously don't know there has been no
diagnosis so
it's it is rumors the fact that they are
circulating however is politically
significant it is evidence of how brutal
this regime is and how quickly it could
unravel how much is held together by
putin and how many people want him dead
if he dies
uh in office then yes a lot of things
change
then the system unravels very fast
i don't think this regime
can actually survive putin
i think we'll have a period of high
turbulence then there will be
realignment there will be coalitions
immediately made
we know who the big players are it's
mikhail michigan particularly sergey
sabanian the moscow mayor um
i think a lot of elites will consolidate
around him there will be somebody from
the security side who will want to
contain the grip on power through
repression
through purges people are starting to
make plans after putin and they're
making their political calculations on
the basis of they're likely to survive
him
which both gives hope and some people
strikes fear
thank you for watching and if you want
to read more of our coverage on russia
and ukraine
please click on the link below
and don't forget to subscribe
you